les gendarmes sont restés jusqu'en fin
de matinée devant la maison de la
famille de maylis pour préserver leur
tranquillité
les parents ont discrètement quitté
mignovillard ce matin sans faire de
déclaration c'est sur les réseaux
sociaux que la mère de la petite fille a
exprimé sa douleur
elle s'adresse pour la première fois à
nordahl le landais le meurtrier présumé
de l'enfant toile assassins de ma fille
maylis va te monte nuit et jour dans sa
prison jusqu'à ce que tu crèves et que
tu aille en enfer écrit-elle dans les
rues du village les habitants pensent
surtout à la famille qui vit ici depuis
quelques années on ne connaît pas la
famille il habite pas loin d'ici
c'est des gens qui sont venus habiter là
mais mes deux petites filles les
connaissent connaissaient très vieille
maëlys et puis la première donc pour
nous c'est qu'on prend bien par à la rpn
et ses terribles grande émotion aussi à
pont de beauvoisin en isère des
habitants déposent des mots et des
peluches devant la salle des fêtes où
maylis a disparu lors d'un mariage
les huit petits enfants donc dont il de
son âge
j'ai pleuré hier c'est la famille des
frissons comme une douleur mais les un
soulagement
en décembre une marche blanche avait été
organisée pour réclamer la vérité sur
cette disparition
tous espèrent maintenant que l' enquête
révélera ce qu'il s'est passé dans la
nuit du 27 août dernier